[Musique]
ce dernier est l'expert mais non mais y
en a qui sont dans mon job
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à rennes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque année
j'ai quand même eu trois saisons choix
dans les bacs depuis ce mois tient alors
d emmanuel car il s'est très bien
intégré
bon on peut parler de colina cessera
bientôt on sera très bien mais je le
sais très bien intégré la preuve qu est
l appareil vous voulez romont
oui c'est pour toi c'est sarenza.com
[Applaudissements]
c'est mieux alors madame lapointe corps
[Musique]
je voudrais
que les spectateurs pour demain mais on
est mal barrés avec ce grand moment de
parler il y avait jean luc alors
jean-luc cplp le faut envoyer là tout
abidjan mais non je pense que chercheur
je veux dire honnêtement je trouvais que
c'était bien intégrés mais quand je dois
à cause de lui lebon tels que c'est
jeudi qu'il n'a pas sa place jules
bordet qui crie c'est vous qui déciderez
[Applaudissements]
parmi nos politiques les pony cars de
guerre
voilà